so 13 reasons why actress Catherine
Langford has been added to the cast list
for Avengers for interesting news and
with this news comes a couple of
questions the two main questions being
are they still doing reshoots for
Avengers 4 and actually not done like
they said they were and what role and
character is she going to play in
Avengers 4 my giveaway still continues
giving away some copies of infinity war
and Ant Man and the wasp on blu-ray as
well as some special edition posters all
you have to do to enter for your chance
to win is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
she was just added to the cast list does
this mean that she's shooting scenes
right now and the answer is no it
doesn't we're just finding out that
she's in the movie right now she's
already shot her scenes Avengers 4
shooting is wrapped it's done right now
they're just editing what they have for
the first trailer to come out which we
found out is going to be in 2018
sometime right now everybody thinks that
she's going to be playing Kate Bishop
who is essentially a female version of
Hawkeye and I think this is the route
that they're going to go down but not
necessarily use Kate Bishop I do think
her character will be the female Hawkeye
especially since Hawkeye is going to
become Ronin in Avengers for it but I
don't think the character will be Kate
Bishop I actually think it's going to be
Clint Barton's daughter Lila Barton who
takes on the mantle of Hawkeye I know
everyone is expecting that
Clint's whole family died from the snap
but this doesn't have to be entirely
true there are four of them not
including Clint you have his wife Laura
his son Cooper and his daughter Lila all
whom we saw an Avengers age of Ultron
and by now his son Nathaniel has been
born so what I'm thinking will happen is
that Laura Cooper and Nathaniel didn't
survive the snap but Lila and Clint did
because you have to tie in the female
version of Hawkeye into a vendor's force
somehow it would be very weird if this
random young girl just sort of joined
the Avengers somehow but making
Hawkeye's daughter Lila become
Hawkeye as Hawkeye becomes Ronin ties
into Avengers for very well and it
actually makes a lot of sense
years and years have gone by since the
events of age of Ultron and Avengers
four is said to take place five years
into the future after the events of
infinity war so Lila is a lot older now
and not to mention Hawkeye retired so he
could go spend time with his family you
don't think he taught her how to shoot a
bow and arrow because you know he did so
now we have Hawkeye who becomes Ronin
and his daughter Lila who becomes
Hawkeye and they both set out to avenge
their family after all that's what the
Avengers are really supposed to be about
avenging this is just a personal theory
of mine but to me this is what seems to
make the most sense but what do you all
think do you think Katherine Langford
will be the female version of Hawkeye
and Avengers 4 and if you don't tell me
who you think she will be let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date with
everything relating to Avengers 4 thank
you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]